[Music]
last night was the premiere of The
Bachelor and Nick filed the new bachelor
Club and hopefully was gonna be the
bachelor forever metha 30 ladies
fighting for his heart and what a
bombshell one of the girls he has
actually been intimate with before so
Nick stopped by et today because well I
mean we needed some answers what did you
think when Liz gets out of the limo I
noticed her right away I mean did you
realize you made it I knew who she was
right but you know I I was like wow
that's Liz you know there's those
moments were like am i right am I wrong
I actually met Nick at Jade and Tanner
sweating and there definitely was a
connection and chemistry there and we
had sex we were with Jade last night at
a charity premiere party at Sycamore
Tavern in LA and she had some questions
of her own I'm curious to why you
weren't more open to hearing Liz out and
giving her a chance to be there and to
see if there really was anything else
I had a fairness to the rest of women I
mean night one there's 30 women and well
I know I definitely had met Liz before I
didn't think Liz deserved any more time
than some of the other women and in fact
even though the conversation did not go
well at all I still gave her a rose to
want to give her that consideration so I
guess I would totally disagree with
Jaden and I think you'll see next week
that conversation actually really
happened an incident in its entirety I
don't know though I mean did you find
laughs maybe if I could tell anyone it
would definitely be well we did see a
ring in last night's promo as well as a
lot of Tears but it almost pales in
comparison to some of this I definitely
can't wait to talk to you more inside I
think it takes a lot of moxie to come
out dressed as a shark and I met Moxon
and then to pretend that you're a
dolphin and she stuck with it so
rapid-fire like a your hardest moment
not losing my mind
figures regret I didn't know how many
women had to sleep there
you'll have to watch you say I mean I
feel like I have this much intuition top
said they're probably not as many as a
lot of people think that much I maybe
know the answer you know
[Music]
you